Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Comme promis, cette semaine, j'ai l'immense plaisir de passer septante minutes avec Julie Dachez.
Julie est docteure en psychologie sociale et se spécialise dans la question de l'autisme. Elle a publié deux bouquins que j'ai beaucoup aimés.
Le premier, c'est une BD qui s'appelle : La Différence invisible, qui est super belle et super touchante. Et le deuxième s'appelle : Dans ta bulle, les autistes ont la parole, écoutons-les,
qui s'inscrit dans une marche qui est beaucoup plus militante.
Et ça tombe bien que Julie milite pour les droits des autistes parce que c'est ce qui avait manqué, je trouve, dans les épisodes précédents.
Dans l'épisode 18, on avait parlé de l'autisme avec les deux professeurs Eric Willaye et Ghislain Magerotte. Et
clairement, leur approche était très médicale et très conservatrice sur certains points, notamment en ce qui concerne l'autisme chez les femmes. Et j'étais sorti
un peu mitigé de cette rencontre. D'où ma joie quand Julie a accepté mon invitation. Cet épisode est un de mes préférés depuis longtemps, et je ne dis pas ça seulement parce qu'elle a presque le même nom que moi,
et j'espère qu'il vous plaira aussi.
C'est parti. Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'immense plaisir de recevoir Julie Dachez. Julie, bonjour.
Bonjour Guillaume.
J'ai un immense plaisir de te recevoir aujourd'hui dans ce podcast. J'ai lu ton livre ce mois-ci et je me suis tout à fait reconnu.
Grand sentiment de validation et grand sentiment de... oui, je me suis reconnu dans ta lutte et dans ton combat.
Se découvrir autiste Asperger, c'est une étape importante dans le parcours d'un ou d'une Aspi. En parler autour de soi, c'est une autre étape très importante.
Toi, tu es allée encore plus loin. Tu as pris la parole publiquement et tu parles de l'autisme dans les médias. Qu'est-ce qui t'a motivée à aller encore plus loin et à mener ce combat ?
Alors en fait, ça a été vraiment quelque chose d'assez progressif. Au début, j'avais envie d'en parler et de sensibiliser
sur la question de l'autisme et à l'époque du syndrome d'Asperger, parce qu'on parlait du syndrome d'Asperger à l'époque, même si maintenant cette appellation, elle a disparu des nomenclatures en vigueur.
J'ai eu envie de le faire parce que je voulais que les prochaines générations n'aient pas à subir ce que moi, j'avais subi, c'est-à-dire l'ignorance, notamment des médecins, le harcèlement à l'école par mes connaissances, etc.
Et de très grandes difficultés d'adaptation et tout et tout. Donc ça m'a semblé être vraiment nécessaire, mais j'ai commencé très tranquillement avec juste le blog au début et des billets.
Puis après, je suis passée à l'étape suivante. J'ai commencé à publier des vidéos, mais toujours pas sous mon vrai nom.
Voilà, c'était sous un pseudo, Super Pépette.
Et je l'ai fait parce que
je me suis dit : « Grâce à ces vidéos, les gens vont pouvoir vraiment voir concrètement à quoi ça ressemble une personne autiste Asperger et peut-être se libérer de certains des clichés qu'ils peuvent avoir en tête.
» Et puis ensuite, la BD est sortie et là, je me suis dit : « Bon, il faut que je la fasse sous mon vrai nom. Y a pas de raison, je vais pas rester au placard.
» Et suite à la BD, ben voilà, y a eu les médias, mais ça a vraiment été quelque chose de très progressif, de très conscient, de très réfléchi,
parce que c'est pas facile d'être ouvertement autiste, vu la façon dont on considère les personnes autistes.
Et voilà, y a pas que des avantages, mais je l'ai fait vraiment en pensant aux générations futures en fait, et en me disant que c'était presque un non-choix.
C'était vraiment une nécessité pour moi de le faire.
D'accord. Donc au début, ça t'effrayait un petit peu de le faire sous ton vrai nom et puis petit à petit, t'y es parvenue.
Tout à fait. Oui, oui, je pense que il me fallait du temps.
Et en fait, au moment où la BD est sortie, la question s'est vraiment posée parce que l'éditeur m'a demandé explicitement : « Voilà, est-ce qu'on met votre nom ou est-ce qu'on met Super Pépette ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on met ? » Et je me suis dit : « Mais je peux pas d'un côté
militer et dire que voilà, qu'il y a pas de honte à être une personne autiste et qu'il faut qu'on sorte du bois, il faut que nos voix soient entendues, etc.
» Et de l'autre, moi, publier un ouvrage sous un pseudonyme. Enfin, là, je voyais un paradoxe et ça m'aurait mis dans un état de dissonance cognitive assez important.
Donc je me suis dit : « Bon là, il faut y aller, il faut être en cohérence avec mes propos » et voilà.
Alors, pour peut-être juste revenir sur ton cas spécifique. Qu'est-ce que... donc tu es autiste Asperger, on l'a dit.
Ton expérience avec l'autisme Asperger, à quoi elle ressemble ? Comment est-ce que ça se présente chez toi ?
En fait, chez moi, c'est un très très grand besoin de solitude. C'est vrai que ça m'épuise d'être en interaction avec des gens.
Alors maintenant que je sais ce que c'est que l'autisme et tout ça, je suis capable d'expliquer pourquoi, mais à l'époque, j'aurais pas su expliquer pourquoi.
Donc voilà. En tout cas, j'ai toujours ressenti ça, cette énorme, énorme fatigue en permanence. Un très fort niveau d'anxiété aussi,
parce que le fait de se suradapter constamment, bah forcément, ça a des conséquences lourdes et l'anxiété en fait partie.
Je pense aussi une très grande
capacité de concentration,
sur les sujets qui m'intéressent. Et quand je suis plongée là-dedans, ce qu'on appelle les fameux intérêts spécifiques, c'est vrai que je peux aller très très loin, être très efficace, abattre beaucoup de travail en peu de temps.
Je vois les détails. Je vois les détails, bon, on sait que c'est, voilà, c'est une caractéristique des personnes autistes, mais ça, je trouve que c'est assez flagrant chez moi aussi.
Ça accroche mon regard.
Tu parlais des intérêts spécifiques. Tes intérêts spécifiques à toi, c'est quoi ?
Alors, depuis quelques années maintenant, ce sont, on va dire, les sciences humaines et sociales et puis surtout, bah du coup, la question de l'autisme et la question aussi du féminisme, beaucoup.
Donc voilà.
Donc c'est peut-être ça aussi qui t'a poussée, si je fais le lien avec ce que tu disais tout à l'heure, c'est peut-être ça aussi qui t'a poussée
à prendre la parole publiquement et à mener ce combat du coup, puisque c'est ton intérêt spécifique et que c'est ta passion
Oui, complètement. Oui, oui, bien sûr.
Je me posais une question puisque tu évoquais donc la perception de l'autisme dans les médias et chez les gens normaux.
On a vu dans ces derniers mois une personnalité émerger qui s'appelle Greta Thunberg-
Mh mh
...qui est donc autiste Asperger. Qu'est-ce que tu as pensé du traitement dans les médias de son autisme ?
Alors,
en fait, c'est génial que tu me poses cette question parce que
justement, quand j'ai vu émerger cette personnalité, je me suis dit : « C'est génial parce que Greta, son combat, il est admirable, elle est extrêmement visible et tout ».
Et elle dit qu'elle est autiste, mais enfin, en fait, elle focalise pas là-dessus. C'est juste qu'elle le dit parce que ça fait partie d'elle.
Ouais.
Et que voilà. Et j'ai trouvé ça génial. Et j'ai pas voulu lire et je n'en ai lu aucun. Je n'ai lu aucun article à son sujet parce que je savais qu'il y aurait forcément des articles violents,
qui décrédibiliseraient sa parole et son combat, justement parce qu'elle est Asperger.
Donc j'ai complètement fait l'autruche. J'ai pas voulu m'exposer à cette violence-là.
Voilà. Bon ben pour info, y avait du très bon et du très mauvais.
Mh. Je me doute.
Qu'est-ce que... ouais. Mais donc on évoquait ton autisme spécifiquement et le fait que donc on l'a pas dit, mais tu étais diagnostiquée quand tu avais 27 ans.
Oui.
Donc adulte. Quand tu étais plus jeune, quand tu étais ado, voire enfant, est-ce que c'est passé complètement inaperçu ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tes parents ont observé, détecté ? Ils se doutaient ou pas du tout ?
Alors, eux se doutaient pas du tout parce qu'ils connaissaient absolument pas, donc ça aurait pas pu leur venir à l'esprit.
Mais je crois que ça a commencé à être vraiment assez visible, flagrant à partir de l'entrée au collège. Et je dis toujours que pour moi, l'entrée au collège, ça a été le début de la fin.
Parce que c'est là où on commence à interagir avec ses pairs sans filet. C'est-à-dire qu'avant ça, on joue toujours, on interagit, mais avec un jeu qui sert d'intermédiaire entre soi et l'autre.
Par exemple, les billes ou les Pokémon ou que sais-je. Mais à l'entrée au collège, rapidement, on parle sans filet.
Et en plus de ça, y a des codes implicites qui se mettent en place, comme les codes vestimentaires,
le vocabulaire qui devient bien spécifique à la préadolescence, des jeux de séduction qui se mettent en place entre les garçons et les filles, des groupes qui se forment.
Et tout ça, c'est basé sur de l'implicite. Et moi, je me suis sentie vraiment complètement larguée. Et là, j'ai commencé à avoir vraiment d'énormes difficultés.
Et malgré tous mes efforts pour essayer de rattraper mon retard, je n'y arrivais pas. Et j'ai commencé à être très très dépressive à cette époque, avoir des idées de mort, etc.
Donc je dirais que vraiment, la préadolescence, ça a été le début de la fin.
Oui. La question qui se pose à ce moment-là, c'est si on avait détecté, diagnostiqué ton autisme à ce moment-là,
avant la préadolescence, est-ce que t'as le sentiment que ta détresse que t'as connue à ce moment-là aurait pu être évitée ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est le destin des personnes autistes de connaître ce genre de trauma ?
En fait, je pense que le diagnostic seul n'aurait pas suffi. C'est-à-dire qu'un diagnostic, c'est important, mais derrière, il faut des accompagnements de qualité.
Oui.
Et je pense pas que j'aurais pu bénéficier d'un accompagnement de qualité, malheureusement. Donc juste balancer le diagnostic comme ça, est-ce que y aurait pas eu justement, c'était ce qu'on appelle la prophétie autoréalisatrice.
Est-ce que je me serais pas convaincue que je n'étais pas capable de faire certaines choses ? Est-ce que je me serais pas complètement inhibée ?
J'en sais rien, en fait. Si j'avais eu un accompagnement de qualité, alors là, c'est sûr, le diagnostic m'aurait sauvée et j'aurais certainement eu une enfance, une jeunesse plus heureuse, plus détendue.
Et voilà, ça aurait été merveilleux, mais sans accompagnement de qualité, euh...
Qu'est-ce que t'entends exactement par un enseignement, un accompagnement de qualité ?
Un accompagnement de qualité, ça aurait été, ben déjà un ou une psychologue spécialisée sur la question, mais qui ne fonctionne pas sur une thérapie basée sur la parole.
Parce que moi, j'en ai vu beaucoup des psys avec une thérapie basée sur la parole et ça ne m'a jamais été utile, mais qui fonctionne par exemple avec des TCC, hein, thérapie cognitive ou comportementale, qui ont fait leurs preuves, notamment
pour les questions de dépression et d'anxiété.
Ça aurait été peut-être bénéficier de groupes de paroles pour pouvoir échanger avec des pairs, peut-être des groupes d'habiletés sociales.
Je pense que ça m'aurait été utile avant la préadolescence. Mais voilà, vraiment un accompagnement hors les murs, bien sûr, pas en institution,
et qui m'aurait permis aussi,
de prendre conscience
de certaines notions déjà sociales, parce que je pense qu'un accompagnement de qualité, c'est à la base évidemment centré sur la personne, mais c'est centré sur la personne au sein d'un contexte sociopolitique plus vaste.
Et je pense que moi, j'aurais été très friande, même en étant jeune, qu'on m'explique, voilà : « En tant que personne autiste, tu fais partie d'une minorité.
Si parfois tu te sens en détresse, c'est parce qu'on te fait sentir en détresse, c'est parce qu'on t'exclut, on te discrimine.
Le problème ne vient pas de toi, le problème est plus vaste, il vient de la société, etc. » Et avoir ce genre de discours, c'est empouvoirant.
Alors c'est un mot qu'on n'utilise pas beaucoup dans un contexte francophone.
Empowerment.
Ouais, c'est de l'empowerment. C'est empouvoirant et je pense que ça peut beaucoup aider les personnes en fait. Mais y a très peu d'accompagnements qui aujourd'hui proposent cet aspect-là.
D'accord. Et donc ce type d'accompagnement que tu n'as donc pas connu adolescente, est-ce que tu l'as connu au moment de ton diagnostic quand tu avais 27 ans ?
Pas du tout.
D'accord. Donc voilà, c'est clair.
J'ai été complètement lâchée dans la nature après mon diagnostic. J'ai eu depuis aucun accompagnement de qualité adapté.
Et du coup, l'accompagnement que tu décris, il est totalement fantasmé, ça n'existe pas.
Alors en tout cas, moi, je l'ai pas vécu, mais je sais que ça existe parce que j'ai eu vent de certains praticiens, praticiennes qui pratiquent.
Et même l'un d'entre eux, un jour, est rentré en contact avec moi et on a échangé un petit peu autour de sa pratique
qui justement, voilà, recoupe un petit peu ces deux dimensions, le psychologique, mais le psychologique dans le social.
Et je trouve ça vraiment passionnant. Donc je sais que ça existe, mais malheureusement, moi, j'en ai pas bénéficié.
Très bien. Et donc en termes de différence de confort avant et après ton diagnostic, puisque tu dis qu'on t'a lâchée
dans la nature comme ça, sans t'aider, qu'est-ce que tu as remarqué comme différence, disons ?
Intérieurement ?
Alors en fait, c'est assez subtil et en même temps ça a changé beaucoup de choses. C'est-à-dire que
moi j'ai pu enfin mettre un mot sur ma différence et ça, ça a été très important pour moi parce que je ne comprenais pas pourquoi je n'arrivais pas à mener la même vie que tout le monde.
C'est-à-dire avoir un travail et en même temps avoir une vie de couple et en même temps avoir une vie sociale. Et moi, tout ça, je n'arrivais pas à le faire.
J'étais épuisée en permanence et voilà. Et donc c'était important de mettre un mot sur ma différence. C'était important de mieux me comprendre, de mieux comprendre mon mode de fonctionnement.
Et ça, ça m'a complètement libérée. Je me suis dit : « Bien, voilà, je ne suis pas une incapable, c'est simplement que je fonctionne différemment.
Je suis autiste et c'est ma normalité à moi. » Et ça, ça a été très important.
Un sentiment de validation quelque part.
Un sentiment de validation.
Je ne suis pas complètement cassé. Oui. Très bien. Alors, on va écouter maintenant un extrait de l'épisode vingt, qui a été publié il y a deux semaines.
Donc j'ai rencontré Hugues Dayet, qui est critique cinéma à la RTBF. Il est le papa d'un garçon qui est autiste Asperger, et qui connaît un autisme, disons, relativement handicapant ou même très handicapant.
Donc on va écouter tout de suite ce qu'il avait à dire à ce sujet. On sent quand même que ton expérience de l'autisme Asperger reste un autisme qui a besoin d'une grande assistance, qui-
Oui.
Qui a, voilà.
Oui. Moi, je sais qu'il y a des Skovanek et tout ça qui parlent sur-
Chauvat, ouais.
Mais pour moi, c'est... enfin, je n'ai jamais rencontré ce monsieur. Tant mieux pour lui s'il se débrouille, mais je pense qu'il rend un très très très mauvais service.
Ah bon ?
Oui, je pense qu'il rend un très mauvais service parce que c'est-à-dire que c'est du showroom, c'est, enfin,
c'est pas de sa faute, mais il fait croire que justement, ben, quelque part, l'autisme, c'est presque une chance.
Et tous ces bouquins et ces conférenciers, etc., qui disent : « Ah... ». Et qui commencent. Moi, je ne peux plus les entendre.
J'ai envie de dire : « Allez, venez vivre vingt-quatre heures ou une semaine avec nous et on en reparle.
» L'autisme au quotidien pendant l'enfance peut... je peux te dire que moi, ça a été des colères où mon fils se roulait par terre pendant trois quarts d'heure.
Et pour le sortir de sa colère, il fallait une heure pour essayer de trouver le sujet de conversation qui allait peut-être pouvoir l'apaiser et le sortir de ses démons intérieurs et de ses peurs et de ses angoisses.
Comme énormément de parents, j'ai vécu des moments totalement épuisants où le soir, on a juste envie soit de prendre des antidépresseurs, soit de se bourrer la gueule.
Les choses sur clés, je dis pas qu'il y a des autistes imposteurs et des autistes profonds.
Ouais.
Je dis simplement que c'est dangereux.
Et en tout cas, c'est biaisé et ça a des effets secondaires que je trouve merdiques de mettre en exergue tel ou tel autiste qui a, entre guillemets, réussi, qui s'en est sorti et de dire : « Ça, c'est l'exemple type de l'autiste.
Donc, vous, parents, vous avez un autiste, surtout ne perdez pas espoir, il arrivera sûrement à être à ce niveau-là un jour. »
Voilà, donc c'était la position de Hugues Dayet, qui est très, disons, violent dans son propos, pour ainsi dire.
Donc il juge visiblement que les personnes autistes qui sont capables, qui sont en capacité d'apparaître dans les médias et de parler de leur autisme,
quelque part, invisibilisent les personnes qui connaissent un autisme, disons, beaucoup plus handicapant.
Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça. Mais en fait, ces propos sont intéressants parce qu'ils sont le reflet de ce que pensent et de ce qu'exprime l'immense majorité des parents d'enfants autistes.
C'est très intéressant.
Moi, je pense que c'est primordial que des personnes autistes comme Joseph, comme moi ou comme d'autres, prennent la parole pour parler de l'autisme.
Et en fait, c'est ça qui est dommage, c'est qu'on ne le fait pas au détriment des personnes autistes qui sont plus dépendantes.
Je pense que chacun peut prendre la parole et coexister.
On le fait justement en ayant toujours ce propos, et là, on est tous sur la même ligne directrice, qui consiste à dire : le handicap n'est pas intrinsèque à la personne, le handicap est une construction sociale.
Et si le handicap est une construction sociale, alors ça veut dire qu'il faut plus de volonté politique, plus de moyens mis à disposition pour pouvoir accompagner les personnes autistes vers plus d'autonomie et vers plus d'épanouissement.
Et ça, en fait, c'est exactement le même discours que les parents d'enfants autistes qui réclament aussi plus de moyens.
Donc nous, voilà, on le fait en prenant la parole, mais le fond de notre discours, en fait, c'est ça.
Et il y a aussi souvent une scission qui est faite entre des autistes qui sont beaucoup plus dépendants que d'autres.
Mais ça, pareil, je pense que c'est important de le rappeler. J'en ai parlé parce que j'ai préparé un petit peu cette émission et j'étais un peu décontenancée face au témoignage de monsieur Dayet.
Et j'en ai parlé avec Amélie de Sagualerne, qui est une camarade à moi, autiste également. Et on a parlé de cette question de la dépendance. Et en fait,
la dépendance, c'est une construction sociale. C'est-à-dire que si dans les pays, on met en place un accompagnement qui est un accompagnement hors les murs,
vraiment un accompagnement de qualité où on pourrait avoir un assistant de vie, par exemple, qui serait présent H vingt-quatre à la maison, qui serait spécialisé sur la condition,
qui saurait gérer les crises, etc.
Alors voilà, ça aussi, ça permet d'autonomiser les personnes autistes. Ça permet de soulager, entre guillemets, les parents, si on part du principe que les enfants autistes peuvent être des fardeaux.
Donc tout ça, c'est pour moi à ramener à une question sociale.
D'accord. Donc, tu estimes que le problème est au niveau de l'assistance qu'on fournit à ces personnes-
Oui.
Et pas tellement au niveau de sa capacité à en parler ou pas. Je,
je tique un petit peu, j'admets, quand tu dis que la dépendance est une construction sociale, puisque voilà, Hugues nous parlait de la situation de son fils qui est donc, il disait, complètement dépendant,
au point où par exemple son fils ne sait pas se raser tout seul.
Mais cette situation où on ne sait pas se raser tout seul, ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on a décidé pour lui, c'est quelque chose de parfaitement naturel pour le coup.
En fait, y a deux choses différentes. Y a d'une part la limitation fonctionnelle de la personne, c'est-à-dire effectivement des incapacités qu'il a, sont là, hein, capacité ou incapacité.
Et ça, bon, ben, c'est comme ça. Et après, y a l'autonomisation, le degré d'autonomie qu'on va réussir à acquérir ou non au sein de la société.
Et ça, pour moi, c'est vraiment à mettre en lien direct avec le modèle social du handicap. C'est-à-dire, par exemple, une personne qui est aveugle et qui veut pouvoir aller en bibliothèque lire un livre.
Si les livres ne sont pas en braille, alors, ben, elle ne peut pas être autonome, elle ne peut pas se rendre dans cette bibliothèque, elle ne peut pas lire de livres et elle est en situation de handicap.
Mais ça, je pense que vraiment, encore une fois, si on fournit les aménagements nécessaires, si on permet de construire une société qui est accessible,
si on permet à cet enfant d'avoir un accompagnement vraiment sur mesure, spécialisé, etc.,
il peut gagner en autonomie, bien sûr, mais la question, ça n'est pas de dire qu'il va devenir comme Joseph Schovanec ou comme moi.
Peut-être que jamais il ne deviendra parfaitement autonome, mais en tout cas, il peut gagner en autonomie. Et c'est en ça qu'on voit que l'autonomie ou la non-autonomie, c'est directement lié au social, en fait.
C'est qu'est-ce qu'on met en place socialement pour permettre aux personnes en situation de handicap de gagner en autonomie.
Oui. Et donc, la question à ce moment-là, c'est aussi de savoir si ce message-là, le message que tu portes aujourd'hui, est toujours bien représenté dans les médias ou bien si--
parce que visiblement, c'est pas le message que lui, il a entendu quand il a allumé sa télé.
Exactement. C'est ça la difficulté, en fait. Oui, oui, complètement.
Mais du coup, donc, on parlait de ces personnes qui passent dans les médias, à la télé pour parler de l'autisme et qui servent,
oui, indirectement ou directement de rôle modèle pour des personnes qui suspectent chez elles une certaine forme d'autisme.
Est-ce que toi, avant d'avoir ton diagnostic, tu as eu des modèles qui ont inspiré ta démarche ?
Est-ce que j'ai eu des modèles ? J'ai lu le livre de Rudy Simone, Aspergirls, qui m'a bien aidée. Donc j'irais pas jusqu'à dire qu'elle a été un modèle, mais en tout cas, son livre m'a bien aidée.
Il t'a inspirée, ouais.
Oui, complètement.
OK.
Mais donc oui, j'aimerais revenir sur ce qu'on disait également y a un instant. Tu n'es pas pour qu'on fasse une scission, qu'on divise
le spectre autistique avec d'un côté les autistes, entre guillemets, visibles et de l'autre côté, les autistes invisibles, si j'ai bien compris.
C'est un peu plus... Je sais pas, c'est vraiment une question complexe. Ben, quand on parlait de dépendance à l'instant.
Et justement, donc y aurait d'un côté les autistes qui sont dépendants et qui ont un fort besoin d'assistance et de l'autre, les autistes qui ne le sont pas.
Mais en fait, c'est assez flou parce qu'on peut l'être plus ou moins. On peut être très dépendant dans l'enfance, puis ensuite-
Oui
...l'être beaucoup moins. On peut être relativement autonome, mais ponctuellement avoir besoin d'assistance tout au long de la vie.
La frontière est floue.
La frontière est extrêmement floue, en réalité. Et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui, on parle de TSA, trouble du spectre autistique au sens large, et qu'on ne fait plus de différence entre Asperger ou autisme Kanner, etc., etc.
C'est parce qu'on sait que les frontières sont bien plus floues que ce qu'on imaginait au départ.
Mmm-hmm. Alors, je vais peut-être dire une bêtise, mais dans le DSM 5, y a le niveau un, deux et trois.
Exactement.
Et c'est justement, si je ne me trompe pas, c'est justement sur base de l'assistance qu'on mesure ça.
Exactement. Mais ça, pareil, ça peut évoluer, en fait, tout au long de la vie.
Donc toi, tu-- OK. Donc, tu estimes que c'était un bon choix ou un mauvais choix, ces trois niveaux sur base de l'assistance ?
Ben, je pense que c'est une nomenclature qui est bien mieux pensée que la nomenclature précédente qui établissait des frontières très nettes entre les différentes catégories d'autisme.
Donc oui, oui, je pense qu'effectivement, c'est intéressant parce que de toute façon, il faut qu'on catégorise, hein.
On est bien obligé, donc il faut bien qu'on trouve des critères pour catégoriser. Mais quand même garder en tête qu'en réalité, c'est plus complexe qu'il n'y paraît. Voilà.
Yes. Tu évoquais tout à l'heure ton expérience quand tu étais au collège. En réaction à ce genre de détresse et d'inconfort que les autistes Asperger peuvent connaître,
ils et elles doivent souvent trouver un mécanisme de compensation pour se défendre face à ces difficultés.
Y a une bonne partie de ta thèse de doctorat qui est consacrée à ce qu'on appelle les stratégies de coping. Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est, les stratégies de coping ?
Oui. Alors en fait, quand on vit une situation stressante,
on la subit passivement. On va mettre en place des réponses, donc qu'il s'agisse de réponses cognitives, affectives ou comportementales, pour essayer de conserver un état psychologique qui va être, on va dire, confortable.
Et donc les stratégies de coping, c'est ça. C'est quelles sont les stratégies qu'on va mettre en place pour faire face aux situations de stress.
Donc après, là aussi, bon, on a mis en place des catégories. Y a différents types de catégories. Y a les stratégies de coping qui sont tournées vers la résolution de problèmes.
Par exemple, si je suis dans un environnement de travail qui est très stressant pour moi avec un manager qui me harcèle, etc., je vais changer de travail et là, j'ai résolu mon problème, hein, je suis dans l'action.
Des stratégies de coping tournées vers la gestion des émotions. Donc, je vais essayer d'apaiser le plus possible les émotions négatives que je ressens, par exemple en allant boire un verre de vin le soir en sortant du travail.
Les stratégies tournées, troisièmement, vers le soutien social. Donc là, je demande de l'aide à des amis, des parents ou autres.
Et les stratégies de coping tournées vers la restructuration cognitive. Donc là, c'est comment est-ce que je vais donner du sens à ce qui m'arrive ?
Comment est-ce que je vais essayer de voir le côté positif des choses, tourner ça à la dérision, etc., etc. Donc y a quatre types, globalement, hein, quatre catégories.
Et voilà, c'est ça, le coping.
D'accord. Je me souviens que dans une de tes très, très vieilles vidéos, du temps de Super Pépette, tu évoquais ce que disait Tony Attwood dans son livre.
Lui parle de quatre stratégies de compensation. Il dit, voilà : « Les dépressions réactives, la fuite dans l'imaginaire, l'imitation », donc le fait de faire le caméléon.
Et puis le combo du déni et de l'arrogance. Donc, est-ce qu'il avait tort ? Qu'est-ce que-- où est-ce qu'on en est à ce niveau-là ?
Ah non, non, pas du tout. C'est qu'en fait-- alors déjà, je pense que lui, quand il parle de stratégie de compensation, il fait référence à complètement autre chose, hein, par rapport aux stratégies de coping.
À mon sens, il fait pas du tout référence au concept du coping.
D'accord
...et on peut très bien avoir, par exemple, une stratégie de coping, si on imagine-- moi, j'en ai identifié huit, hein, chez les personnes autistes en déficience intellectuelle.
Par exemple, les intérêts spécifiques. J'ai identifié que c'était une stratégie de
coping. Le fait de se consacrer à son intérêt spécifique, ça permet de s'apaiser émotionnellement et ça permet-- donc ça, là, ça veut dire que c'est tourné vers la gestion des émotions.
Et ça permet aussi parfois de trouver des réponses à des questions qu'on se pose, c'est-à-dire, on voit y a des personnes autistes qui se prennent de passion, par exemple, pour la psychologie et ça leur permet-
Mmh
...de mieux comprendre l'humain, de mieux comprendre intellectuellement les interactions sociales. Et donc là, on voit que c'est une stratégie de coping qui peut être aussi tournée vers la résolution de problèmes.
Donc en fait, cette nomenclature qui a été établie, hein, résolution de problèmes, gestion des émotions, restructuration cognitive, soutien social.
Comme toujours, on a quatre catégories comme ça, mais en réalité, elles sont interdépendantes, elles communiquent les unes avec les autres.
Et les stratégies de coping qu'on identifie, on va essayer de les rapporter à l'une, à l'autre, voilà, ou à plusieurs d'entre elles.
Et dans une de tes vidéos, ce que tu disais aussi, c'est que le militantisme, donc typiquement des choses comme le féminisme, l'antispécisme, etc.,
c'est quelque chose qu'on remarque assez souvent, si j'ai bien compris, assez souvent chez les autistes Asperger et en particulier les femmes.
Alors, je crois que c'est plus lié à cette même recherche. En fait, j'ai identifié que pour certaines personnes autistes
diagnostiquées à l'âge adulte, le militantisme, mais plutôt tourné spécifiquement vers la question de l'autisme, c'est une façon pour eux et pour elles de gérer les situations compliquées qu'ils ou elles ont vécues.
C'est une façon de donner du sens en fait à leur vécu.
D'accord.
Et c'est un petit peu ce que j'ai fait, hein. Voilà, c'était plus dans ce contexte-là, il me semble.
Ouais, d'accord. Quelque chose que moi, je remarque, mais vraiment,
mon expérience personnelle avec les autistes Asperger et en particulier de nouveau les femmes, c'est-- je remarque vraiment une assez grande capacité à
s'émanciper des conventions sociales, à remettre les choses en question.
Et voilà, et typiquement, ben oui, le patriarcat, typiquement, c'est-- je remarque une très grande capacité, de nouveau, c'est mon expérience, peut-être que ça ne vaut rien du tout,
à-- davantage que les neurotypiques à se libérer de ça.
Est-ce que tu rejoins ce que je dis ou pas du tout ?
C'est une bonne question. Je sais pas. C'est-- tu vois, faudra que j'y réfléchisse parce que là, je sais pas.
OK, y a pas de souci. Parce que donc, de nouveau, ce que moi, je remarque dans ta bande dessinée, « La différence invisible », c'est que tu évoques rapidement tes convictions antispécistes.
Est-ce que t'estimes que c'est lié à, voilà, à ton état d'autisme ? D'autiste, pardon.
Je crois-- alors ça, par contre, c'est vrai que je crois que globalement, on a une sensibilité à l'égard des questions macro.
C'est-à-dire, y a beaucoup de personnes autistes qui sont très concernées, ben comme Greta, par les questions environnementales, par la question de la souffrance animale, etc., etc.
D'ailleurs, c'est intéressant de le noter parce que souvent, on parle d'empathie et un des clichés, c'est que les personnes autistes sont dénuées d'empathie.
En réalité, c'est plus complexe que ça. Et on voit bien notamment qu'en fait, à un niveau macro, on a une empathie qui est très très, très très développée, très très exacerbée.
Donc ça, c'est vrai qu'on est souvent sensible aux questions sociales, environnementales. Moi, après, je dirais que personnellement, mes prises de conscience--
en fait, quand on commence à prendre conscience des oppressions et qu'on commence à tirer le fil, on se rend compte que tout est lié.
Et je crois aujourd'hui que je pourrais pas militer sur la question de l'autisme sans parler en même temps de féminisme, sans parler en même temps de racisme.
Parce que tout ça est lié, tout ça se, voilà, et ce-- bon, on peut parler d'intersectionnalité, c'est un peu-
Voilà, c'est ça. C'est ça. J'allais dire, tu es très inter-, tu es très intertex-- ouh là là. Tu es très intersectionnelle dans ton propos.
Dans mon approche, oui oui, complètement. Je crois que c'est vraiment fondamental et ça a d'autant plus de sens sur la question de l'autisme, que on sait que, ben voilà, les femmes autistes ont des vécus bien particuliers.
Mais je crois qu'on va y revenir, qu'il est vraiment urgent de mettre en lumière
qu'y a beaucoup plus de personnes trans parmi les autistes que chez les non autistes et que donc ça aussi, quand on est trans et autiste, ah ben là, on a des parcours de vie particulièrement chaotiques.
On a aussi souvent une orientation sexuelle qui s'écarte de la norme. Donc pour l'autisme, la question de l'intersectionnalité, elle a d'autant plus-- c'est pas facile à dire, ce mot.
Elle a d'autant plus de sens en fait. Et elle est vraiment cruciale, je crois.
Yes, mais donc tu évoques un sujet que je trouve fascinant, c'est donc la capacité ou le
fait que régulièrement, chez les personnes autistes, on observe effectivement cette capacité à dévier des normes en termes de sexualité, en termes de genre.
À quoi est-ce qu'on attribue ça exactement ?
Aujourd'hui, on n'a pas la réponse. Aujourd'hui, on n'a pas la réponse. Mais c'est vrai que comme on est peut-être un peu plus résistant aux normes sociales, et sans s'en rendre compte, on s'autorise plus de choses.
Parce que bon, le genre, c'est une construction sociale. Donc voilà, peut-être qu'on laisse s'exprimer certaines choses plus facilement.
J'en sais rien.
Oui. Moi, j'en suis vraiment convaincu de ça, que y a vraiment un côté où on échappe un petit peu aux conventions, parce que-- je sais pas, peut-être un lien moins émotionnel.
Je ne sais pas.
C'est possible
...mais j'en suis vraiment convaincu.
Ben je sais que moi, à titre personnel, la question de mon genre, elle a toujours été, euh-- je me suis jamais-- enfin, je n'ai jamais adhéré aux stéréotypes de genre.
Je me suis jamais considérée comme une femme avec tous les attributs de la femme.
J'ai un genre qui est très fluctuant, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des périodes où j'ai envie d'être féminine et il y a d'autres où, voilà, je vais me couper les cheveux très très courts et mettre des vêtements
plus masculins pour me camoufler, etc.
Enfin, et je l'ai toujours vécu comme ça et bon, ça fait partie de moi en fait. Donc, et c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui revient très souvent, notamment chez les femmes autistes, hein, ce côté-
Ouais
...un peu, un peu, un peu masculin.
J'ai une amie, une amie aspi qui dit exactement la même chose, dans-- vis-à-vis du genre, de temps en temps un peu plus masculin, de temps en temps...
Voilà. Ouais.
Ouais, c'est assez typique. Et ce que dit Tony Attwood, et de nouveau, c'est son propos, c'est son expérience, je sais pas si c'est vrai, mais il dit : « The typical aspie girl is a tomboy.
» Donc la fille aspi typique est, entre guillemets, un garçon manqué. Donc ça a l'air assez récurrent tout de même, ouais.
Oui. Oui.
OK. Bah alors, on va tout doucement s'approcher de la question de l'autisme chez les femmes.
J'en avais parlé avec le docteur Eric Willaye quand je l'ai rencontré,
y a un petit mois au Susa à Mons, et il avait une position assez prudente, assez sceptique vis-à-vis de la question de l'autisme chez les femmes.
On écoute tout de suite Eric Willaye. Qu'est-ce qui fait que chez les femmes, c'est plus compliqué que chez les hommes ?
On n'a aucune donnée à l'heure actuelle par rapport à ça. Voilà, OK. Non, non, il y a des recherches qui sont en cours. Enfin, et voilà, y a quelques articles qui parlent de ça, mais à l'heure actuelle, on ne peut pas faire-- on ne peut pas instituer
comme état de fait que les femmes sont moins bien diagnostiquées que les hommes.
Ça, c'est clair. Ah. Donc vous, vous allez même une étape avant ça. Vous dites : « Si ça se trouve... » Y en a pas autant, ça, c'est très clair.
Chez nous, depuis 30 ans, le pourcentage garçon-fille ne varie pas d'1 %. Mais est-ce que c'est parce que les femmes avec autisme n'existent pas avec un nombre, une quantité semblable à celle des hommes ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est parce qu'elles n'ont pas les difficultés que ressentent les hommes et qu'elles se camouflent beaucoup mieux et que donc elles ne viennent pas ?
Si elles ne viennent pas, nous sommes dans l'incapacité de dire qu'elles existent ou non. Donc, mais dire qu'elles e-, 'fin, qu'elles existent
alors qu'on n'a pas la preuve qu'il s'agit d'un diagnostic spécifique, ça, ça me pose un problème parce qu'on semble dire de prendre pour état de fait que l'on ne diagnostique pas suffisamment les femmes.
Bah, j'attends de voir, hein, j'attends de voir parce qu'à l'heure actuelle, y a pas nécessairement de, 'fin, de réalité à cette situation clinique.
Voilà. Donc, Eric Willaye est très prudent et très sceptique vis-à-vis de la question de l'autisme chez les femmes. Qu'est-ce que tu penses des positions de ce professeur ?
Alors. En fait, les critères diagnostics de l'autisme, ils ont été établis à partir de l'étude de cas masculins. Ça, on le sait hein.
Donc on a observé des petits garçons et on a établi une grille, voilà, diagnostic à partir de ça. Donc forcément, y a un biais de genre.
Ça, on peut pas le nier. Y a un biais de genre. Et en plus de ça, y a quelques recherches quand même qui existent sur le sujet et de plus en plus.
On voit très bien que, chez les femmes autistes, l'autisme se présente de façon plus subtile. Elles ont des meilleures compétences de communication.
Alors, on y reviendra certainement, mais pas parce que c'est inné hein, parce que c'est acquis, parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes attentes sociales à l'égard des petites filles, qu'on les socialise différemment.
Donc on attend d'elles qu'elles soient plus chaleureuses, plus avenantes, plus sociables, etc. Donc voilà, les petites filles autistes n'échappent pas à cette règle.
Donc elles ont de meilleures compétences de communication. Elles ont des intérêts spécifiques qui sont plus socialement acceptables.
Là où les petits garçons vont se prendre de passion pour les plans de métro, par exemple, les petites filles vont se prendre de passion pour les chevaux.
Donc c'est avec la même intensité, mais comme c'est socialement plus acceptable, eh bien, ça va un peu moins interpeller l'entourage.
Et en plus de ça, elles se camouflent mieux, elles observent leurs congénères et elles les imitent. Et donc, à l'âge adulte, entre le fait que les critères diagnostics ne soient pas adaptés au cas des femmes et qu'en plus de ça,
elles aient de meilleures compétences de communication et qu'elles camouflent mieux leurs difficultés et tout ça, eh bien forcément qu'elles passent entre les mailles du filet diagnostic.
Donc ça, aujourd'hui, c'est une évidence, mais on ne sait pas, on n'est pas en capacité de dire quel est le sexe ratio, s'il y a tant d'hommes autistes pour de femmes autistes.
Aujourd'hui, on dit que c'est une femme autiste pour quatre hommes autistes. Mais en réalité, on ne sait pas, parce que c'est biaisé.
Ce chiffre-là, il est biaisé. Donc attendons de voir dans les années qui viennent, la façon dont les choses vont évoluer.
Je ne doute pas que certainement, il y ait des grilles diagnostics qui soient établies pour les femmes autistes. Voilà.
Yes. Mais ce que je remarque, c'est qu'à tes yeux, c'est évident. Aux yeux du professeur, ce n'était pas du tout évident. Donc, tu-
Mais oui, parce qu'en fait, je pense que pour que ça soit évident, il faut avoir vraiment une lecture féministe sur cette question-là.
Il faut vraiment s'être intéressé aux études de genre, pour, voilà, pour avoir cette lecture que moi, j'ai.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est si important de croiser les regards, en fait, et de faire des recherches aussi interdisciplinaires et tout ça et voilà. Donc-
Ouais
...bon.
Je rejoins totalement ta position et c'est d'ailleurs
un petit peu mon grand regret vis-à-vis de cet épisode, c'est que voilà, pour le dire poliment, le professeur Eric Willaye et Ghislain Magerotte, effectivement, on sentait qu'ils étaient pas tout à fait à jour vis-à-vis de ça.
Mais ce que je trouve intéressant, c'est que tu dis, tu es très assertive et tu juges que c'est parfaitement de l'acquis.
Ça n'est pas de l'inné, cette différence qu'on observe chez les filles et chez les garçons, c'est un comportement acquis, d'après toi.
C'est difficile de pouvoir vraiment le dire à 100 %, mais en tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'on n'est pas éduqué de la même manière.
Ça, on le sait, on est socialisé différemment entre garçons et filles. C'est la même chose pour les garçons et les filles autistes.
Donc forcément que ça joue. Mais c'est toujours pareil, où placer le curseur entre inné et acquis ? Mais ça, je défie quiconque d'avoir la réponse en fait.
Mais moi, je suis plutôt dans une perspective, oui, constructiviste quoi. Donc oui, pour moi, c'est plutôt de l'acquis.
C'est ça. Mais donc en gros, la question à se poser, c'est : si c'était de l'inné, est-ce que l'acquis aurait tout de même un impact ?
Et je pense que c'est assez clair qu'il a dans tous les cas un impact très important. Ça, c'est certain.
Et toi, est-ce que t'estimes, sur base de ton expérience personnelle, que t'aurais été diagnostiquée peut-être plus tôt si tu n'avais pas connu ces, voilà, ces biais, cette discrimination genrée
Oui, mais ça n'est pas que lié à ça. Le syndrome d'Asperger, puisqu'à l'époque, c'est ce qui prévalait,
il est rentré dans les classifications au début des années 90, tant dans le DSM que dans la CIM, hein, la CIM qui est la classification européenne et le DSM qui est la classification nord-américaine.
Donc début des années 90, moi, je suis née en 85.
Forcément, enfin ma génération, les générations d'avant, on est un petit peu des générations sacrifiées parce qu'en fait, l'autisme et le syndrome d'Asperger, c'était très très, très très peu connu.
Yes. Et donc ça pose un petit peu aussi la question de, voilà, ces deux professeurs sont ce qu'on appelle des cliniciens.
Ils travaillent, je dirais, à un niveau micro, presque, 'fin, pas un niveau biologique, mais un niveau technique, on va dire.
Mais ils ont très bien pu parler, voilà, des neurones miroirs, des différences comportementales à l'échelle individuelle.
Toi, tu as fait le choix de faire ton doctorat sur un domaine qui est relativement rare, quand on parle de l'autisme, c'est la psychologie sociale.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est ? Qu'est-ce que c'est la psychologie sociale et, dans le cadre de l'autisme, comment ça s'applique ?
Alors, c'est une question compliquée. En fait, donc en psychologie, on a différentes branches. On a la psychologie clinique qui s'intéresse aux causes, aux symptômes, aux traitements, etc.,
notamment, et aussi la psychologie sociale qui s'intéresse à la façon dont les individus vont être influencés par les autres, par les normes et tout ça.
Moi, j'ai coutume de dire,
c'est peut-être un peu
caricatural, mais que bon, la psychologie, ça se situe vraiment à un niveau
individuel, ça s'intéresse à la personne, la sociologie s'intéresse au groupe et la psychologie sociale, ça s'intéresse à la façon dont le groupe vient influencer l'individu et parfois aussi réciproquement.
Voilà, donc c'est un peu à l'intersection entre les deux. J'ai fait ce choix-là parce que, moi, l'autisme, je n'avais aucun intérêt à l'étudier du point de vue de la psychologie clinique,
parce que pour moi, c'est une façon différente d'être au monde, ce qui ne veut pas dire que ça ne pose pas certaines difficultés, hein, évidemment.
Mais en tout cas, je voyais aucun intérêt à m'intéresser aux symptômes, aux traitements, aux causes, bla bla bla.
Donc j'ai fait le choix de la psychologie sociale en me disant : « Ben voilà, intéressons-nous plutôt aux attitudes à l'égard de l'autisme, intéressons-nous aux représentations sociales de l'autisme, intéressons-nous
aux stratégies de coping mobilisées par les personnes autistes.
» Et là, ça va nous dire autre chose, ça va nous permettre d'élargir un peu la focale et de voir quelle perception on a de l'autisme, voilà.
Pour faire très très simple. Et c'était vraiment atypique parce que, à ma connaissance, hein, c'est la première thèse qui porte sur l'autisme du point de vue de la psychologie sociale en France.
Mh.
Et même dans le monde, il y a assez peu de chercheurs en psychosocial qui travaillent sur la question de l'autisme.
Oui. Ce que tu dis, à la fin de ton livre, quand tu, dans le dernier chapitre de ton livre, c'est quand tu présentes ta thèse,
pour terminer ton doctorat, ce que tu dis, c'est que tu as dû, si j'ai bien compris, réécrire ta conclusion qui était jugée trop politisée.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de ça ?
Alors ça, c'est vraiment intéressant parce que, évidemment, moi, j'ai fait ma thèse et j'ai soutenu ma thèse en étant une personne ouvertement autiste qui produit un travail de recherche sur l'autisme.
C'est très mal vu en France, mais pas que, hein, je pense qu'en Belgique, c'est la même chose. Dans les pays anglo-saxons, ils sont un peu plus ouverts sur la question, mais bon, dans le monde académique francophone, c'est assez mal vu,
quand on est une personne directement concernée par son objet d'étude.
Et les féministes ont fait,
ont fait face à ce même genre de problème. Quand les femmes ont voulu commencer à s'emparer des questions de genre, etc., à produire des recherches féministes et tout ça,
les hommes leur sont tombés dessus à bras raccourcis en disant qu'elles ne pouvaient absolument pas prétendre à faire de la recherche parce qu'elles n'étaient pas suffisamment objectives pour cela, parce qu'elles étaient parties prenantes,
sans prendre conscience qu'eux aussi étaient parties prenantes, puisque eux, voilà, sont les dominants dans l'histoire, les femmes sont les dominées.
Et en réalité, tout le monde a sa propre subjectivité. Et on oublie trop souvent que lorsqu'on est chercheur, chercheuse, de par notre appartenance politique, religieuse, de par notre genre, de par notre classe sociale, etc.,
on va aborder notre objet d'étude avec un certain regard.
Donc, les personnes directement concernées par leur objet d'étude, tout de suite, on dit : « Oh là là, mais vous qui êtes autiste, comment vous pouvez prétendre être suffisamment objective pour produire un travail de recherche sur l'autisme ?
» Alors qu'en réalité, la neutralité axiologique est un mythe. L'objectivité pure et parfaite n'existe pas, mais on peut tendre vers l'objectivation.
On peut et on doit le faire en tant que chercheur et chercheuse. Et pour cela, il faut déjà avoir conscience de sa subjectivité.
C'est un premier pas pour tendre vers l'objectivité. On voit le chercheur comme une personne qui est dans sa tour d'argent un petit peu,
déconnectée hein, et qui doit avoir un regard parfaitement objectif, c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure, sur son objet d'étude.
Mais en fait, ça, c'est un leurre. Ça n'existe pas. Donc c'est beaucoup plus sain d'avoir une position extrêmement claire et de dire : « Bah voilà, moi, j'ai un point de vue », ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs un point de vue situé hein,
« je suis directement concerné par mon objet d'étude.
Voilà quelles sont mes convictions. Voilà comment j'ai travaillé à l'objectivation de mes recherches. » Ça, c'est intéressant.
Là, vraiment, on dit quelque chose et là, on prend conscience de sa subjectivité
et on dit quelque chose sur nous-mêmes en tant que chercheurs, nous-mêmes, comment on se positionne dans le système et comment on positionne notre recherche dans le système.
Et alors, ceci étant dit, pour moi, tout est politique. Et la psychologie, c'est, je pense, un des défauts majeurs de cette discipline, c'est que la psychologie, elle se pense en étant complètement déconnectée du monde social.
Trop souvent, hein, on s'intéresse à l'individu, mais on ne s'intéresse pas à l'individu dans un contexte sociopolitique plus vaste.
Alors qu'en fait, l'individu, on ne peut pas juste l'extraire du monde, le mettre dans une pièce fermée, dans une, voilà, dans une salle d'expérimentation, voir comment il réagit, etc.,
et extrapoler en se disant : « Ben voilà, l'individu réagit comme ça, tous les individus réagissent comme ça » et euh, et ça permet d'expliquer tel ou tel phénomène.
C'est assez artificiel. Et la psychologie ne se rend pas compte aussi qu'en fait, en n'ayant pas une vision critique sur elle-même, elle peut entretenir certains rapports de pouvoir entre dominant-dominé.
Et notamment, par exemple, toutes les personnes qui sont bipolaires, schizophrènes ou autres, à aucun moment la psychologie n'a pour but justement de les empouvoirer.
On en revient encore à cette question-là. La psychologie, elle a pour but de les voir comme des personnes qui ont des problèmes, des déficits et qu'il faut guérir, réparer, et cetera.
Donc c'est une vision qui vraiment va entretenir le statu quo, entretenir les relations de pouvoir dominant-dominé qui ne se remet pas en question.
Mais il y a l'apparition, mais ça, dans les pays francophones, pareil, on n'en parle pas du tout, d'un nouveau courant au sein de la psychologie, ou plutôt un contre-courant qui s'appelle la psychologie critique
et qui vise justement à révéler la façon dont la psychologie va avoir un rôle dans les relations de pouvoir entre dominant-dominé, et cetera, et de mettre à jour ce rôle-là et d'essayer d'en sortir.
Et donc moi, j'ai parlé dans ma conclusion, j'ai parlé de ça, j'ai parlé un petit peu de la psychologie critique.
Et eux, ça les a, bah choqués parce qu'ils ont pas l'habitude que des personnes tiennent ce genre de propos.
Mmh.
Et ils ont vu ça comme un défaut,
euh. Voilà, mais c'est vraiment intéressant en fait. Tout ça, c'est une question de posture épistémologique et ça en dit long, hein, sur l'état de la recherche aujourd'hui quoi.
Et donc, tu donnais, si je comprends bien, hein, tu donnais des propos anticapitalistes dans ta conclusion et tu as dû les retirer ?
Bof, oui, peu ou prou, c'est ça, oui.
D'accord, OK.
Peu ou prou, c'est ça. Ouais.
On va peut-être un petit peu maintenant se tourner, puisque tu tiens à politiser ton discours, ce qui est très bien, on va peut-être se tourner un petit peu vers l'avenir.
Ce que mon expérience et ce que j'entends régulièrement quand j'écoute des témoignages
d'autistes Asperger, c'est qu'y a de nombreux psys qui ont un énorme blocage avec la notion de, voilà, d'étiquette, de poser un diagnostic, de, ils emploient le mot parfois,
enfermer dans une case.
Et donc, voilà, souvent, ou alors ils sont carrément juste ignares en la matière. Souvent, on retrouve ce cas,
le scénario du ou de la jeune aspi qui tombe un peu par hasard sur le mot Asperger en faisant des recherches sur Google et sur Wikipédia.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce que tu racontes dans ta bande dessinée. Est-ce qu'on peut espérer que ça change, dans l'avenir ?
Et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour provoquer ce changement ?
Mmh. Alors c'est une bonne question.
Bon déjà, c'est vrai que c'est inacceptable,
les médecins, les psys qui ont ce genre de propos, hein,
qui disent : « Mais voyons, vous êtes pas un pot de confiture, vous n'avez pas besoin d'une étiquette, vous avez pas besoin d'une case qui vous enferme », et cetera, parce que le diagnostic n'est pas une case qui enferme. Le diagnostic-
C'est libère
...c'est libère, ça permet de comprendre qui on est.
Bah oui, clairement.
Et ça permet aussi, ça, c'est très important, d'avoir accès à des aides en fait, des aides humaines, des aides matérielles, et cetera.
Donc c'est vraiment très très important d'en passer par cette étape. Après, que faire pour que les choses évoluent ?
Je pense que déjà, il faudrait qu'il y ait plus de formation sur la question de l'autisme, à l'université, voilà, quand les médecins se forment et notamment les psychiatres, mais pas que.
Je pense que vraiment, il faudrait étendre la formation et que des personnes directement concernées viennent s'exprimer, en fait.
Voilà, que ça soit pas juste un savoir,
descendant, vertical d'un soi-disant expert qui a étudié le sujet de façon théorique, vis-à-vis d'étudiants et étudiantes, mais que les personnes directement concernées puissent venir s'exprimer, et notamment sur la question du diagnostic.
Et là, je pense que peut-être, les lignes bougeraient un peu plus.
Oui. Ben c'est ce que disait donc le professeur Hercouët quand je l'ai interviewé, c'est qu'effectivement, dans les cursus de médecine, de
psychologie, de pédagogie ou quoi que ce soit, l'autisme est soit, enfin il est généralement
complètement ou presque complètement absent.
Mais par contre, il y a, voilà, la possibilité, si on s'intéresse très fort à l'autisme, de se spécialiser. Et là, on peut se former vraiment
en profondeur, mais c'est très très optionnel et y a très peu de gens qui le font. Euh-
C'est vraiment absurde quand on sait que l'autisme, ça concerne une personne sur 150.
C'est la question que je voulais poser. Étant donné qu'on est aussi nombreux, et que le problème, voilà, on en parle de plus en plus dans les médias, dans la presse,
comment est-ce qu'on explique cette absence du cursus ?
Mmh. J'en sais rien.
Non, mais c'est clair, c'est clair, c'est la seule réponse.
C'est navrant. Mais non, je sais pas pourquoi. Je sais pas. Et je sais que
moi, je, bon ba, malheureusement, je vais parler de la France parce que c'est ce que je connais, mais dans l'université de Nantes, y a encore pas si longtemps, j'ai des étudiants et des étudiantes qui me rapportaient
que dans leur cours de psychologie clinique, le prof leur disait que l'autisme était une psychose, que l'autisme, c'est l'autoérotisme, le plaisir d'être avec soi, et cetera, et cetera.
Tout un tas de nouilles psychanalytiques. Et on est en 2019 quoi, donc euh...
Donc ouais, je vais juste rebondir sur quelque chose que tu as dit à l'instant. Tu disais une personne sur 150.
Ça, c'est le chiffre qu'on cite souvent.
Mmh.
Est-ce que tu as personnellement le sentiment que ce sont des bons chiffres ? Est-ce que tu crois à ce ratio ?
Je ne sais pas. En tout cas, peut-être c'est intéressant là, de faire une petite parenthèse sur la soi-disant épidémie qu'il y aurait d'autisme.
On entend souvent parler de ça. On dit : « Oh là là, y a de plus en plus de personnes autistes. Mon Dieu, c'est une épidémie », avec en plus les fausses informations sur le lien entre vaccins et autisme.
Et ça, c'est totalement faux, mais il faut le dire et le redire, les vaccins ne causent pas l'autisme, pas du tout. La recherche a maintes et maintes fois débouté cette idée.
Donc voilà. Et en fait, il n'y a pas d'épidémie d'autisme. Ça, c'est très important de le dire. Il n'y a pas de plus en plus de personnes autistes, mais il y a de plus en plus de personnes autistes diagnostiquées.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on a élargi les critères diagnostics et qu'en plus de ça, c'est une condition qui est de mieux en mieux connue et donc de mieux en mieux repérée par les médecins, les parents, les instituteurs, et cetera, et cetera.
Et ça c'est important de le dire vraiment parce que le problème c'est qu'avec cette espèce de crainte là,
de l'épidémie d'autisme, ça permet à tout un tas de personnes de s'engouffrer là-dedans et de vendre des soi-disant remèdes miracles hein, remèdes new age et compagnie.
Parce que l'autisme, c'est aussi un marché fructueux. Et quand on a des parents qui sont désespérés, c'est facile de leur vendre tout et n'importe quoi et de leur faire peur, etc.
Bref, donc ça il faut vraiment le dire, y a pas de plus en plus de personnes autistes.
J'aimerais juste revenir sur la notion d'épidémie, de soi-disant épidémie. Ce que nous disait donc le professeur Eric Mulay, c'est que parmi les facteurs qui peuvent
influer sur la probabilité que l'enfant soit autiste, voilà y a certains facteurs qui ont été identifiés, comme par exemple le fait d'avoir des parents plus âgés.
On remarque que plus les parents sont âgés pendant la grossesse, plus la statistique augmente. Et justement, on sait qu'on est dans une période de plus en plus, enfin jamais assez, mais de plus en plus émancipatrice.
Et on a effectivement, dans certaines populations, de plus en plus la possibilité pour les femmes d'être enceintes de plus en plus tard.
Et donc c'est le genre de facteurs, disons indirects,
sociétaux, culturels, qui pourraient à terme, enfin c'est juste une théorie à deux balles que j'ai, mais qui pourrait influer sur la quantité d'autistes, non ?
Oui, complètement. Mais c'est vrai que moi, ça me débecte assez les discours sur les causes en fait. Savoir d'où ça vient, etc.
Parce qu'en fait ce qui—
C'est la science, c'est la curiosité
...ce qui est sous-jacent. Oui, tout à fait. Mais ce qui est très souvent sous-jacent derrière ça, et notamment dans les études génétiques, savoir d'où ça vient, c'est—
L'eugénisme
...espérer un jour faire en sorte que, ben en fait, y ait plus de personnes autistes quoi. C'est la détection in utero.
Et ça, ça me fait très très peur en fait. Donc...
Oui, je suis tout à fait d'accord pour dire que ces discours-là font peur, mais après, je pense qu'il faut quand même laisser à la science la liberté de s'intéresser à tout.
Ah ben oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr. Mais du coup, c'est vrai que moi, je m'intéresse assez peu à ces questions-là. Voilà, pour ces raisons-là.
D'accord, OK. Alors, on va revenir sur la spécificité des femmes autistes. Dans ton livre, tu dis : « Les femmes autistes sont naïves et influençables.
Elles ont du mal à décoder les intentions des personnes qui les entourent, ce qui fait d'elles des proies rêvées pour les prédateurs en tout genre, notamment sexuels.
» Est-ce que c'est ton expérience, le fait d'avoir été souvent, qu'on ait profité de ta naïveté ? Est-ce que c'est ton expérience ?
Oui, ben la mienne, mais pas que. Mais combien de fois je me suis retrouvée dans des situations, face à un homme qui me saute dessus.
Et pour lui, c'était évident en fait qu'on était dans une espèce de parade nuptiale depuis des semaines, voire des mois.
Moi, j'avais rien vu venir quoi. Et lui était dans un jeu de séduction et moi, je ne l'avais pas vu. J'étais juste en train de me dire : « Ben voilà, c'est quelqu'un de très sympathique avec qui je passe de bons moments ».
Enfin, vraiment. Et comme à aucun moment je n'ai
opposé, enfin voilà, à aucun moment je n'ai dit non ou à aucun moment je n'ai fait en sorte de les conduire ou quoi, parce que je n'ai rien vu venir, lui a pris ça pour une invitation et donc une invitation à me sauter dessus quoi.
Et ça, c'est évidemment mon vécu, mais pas que hein. Donc, pff. Mais alors après, oui, les femmes autistes ont du mal à décoder l'implicite et donc elles se retrouvent dans ce genre de situation.
Mais évidemment, ça veut pas dire que c'est leur responsabilité hein. C'est—
Les femmes et les hommes, on est d'accord.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, tout à fait. Oui, y a aussi beaucoup d'abus sexuels chez les hommes autistes hein.
Ah oui, ah ça, c'est intéressant. Donc plus que chez les neurotypiques.
Je n'ai pas les chiffres et je crois pas qu'on ait les chiffres à l'heure actuelle, mais en tout cas, j'entends autour de moi des camarades autistes masculins me parler, voilà, d'abus qu'ils ont vécu hein.
Et du coup, pour les hommes et pour les femmes aspies qui ont connu ou qui sont en passe malheureusement de connaître ce genre de situation,
qu'est-ce que— alors évidemment, on le répète, la responsabilité est du côté sociétal, politique et ainsi de suite.
Mais dans l'état actuel des choses, qu'est-ce que tu conseillerais à ces hommes et à ces femmes aspies pour se protéger d'une telle éventualité ?
En fait, pour moi, c'est toujours compliqué d'avoir ce genre de discours parce que se protéger, mais en fait le problème, c'est l'agresseur.
Donc il faudrait éduquer tout le monde à la question du consentement. Tout le monde, mais surtout les hommes, hein, parce que ce sont les hommes dans l'immense majorité, les violeurs, les agresseurs.
Mhm.
Donc éduquer tout le monde à la question du consentement dès le plus jeune âge, avec un focus particulier sur les femmes en situation de handicap, parce qu'on le sait qu'elles sont, autistes ou pas hein, qu'elles sont d'autant plus vulnérables
à la question des agressions sexuelles et des viols.
Et pour les femmes, par exemple autistes, qui sont non verbales, pouvoir mettre en place des éducations, des interventions éducatives basées sur des visuels, qui permettent,
voilà, d'expliquer sans passer par le verbal,
des interventions éducatives qui soient adaptées en fait à leurs particularités.
Et ça, c'est très important. Et alors,
je sais qu'aujourd'hui, les choses ont un petit peu évolué à l'école, mais moi, à mon époque, jamais, jamais, jamais, je n'ai eu de cours sur le consentement et j'ai découvert ce qu'était le consentement à l'âge de 30 ans.
À l'âge de 30 ans. Donc c'est quand même—
Ah ouais.
C'est quand même hallucinant. C'est quand même hallucinant en fait. Et je ne suis pas la seule. Je ne suis pas la seule.
Donc comme en plus, on est éduqué en tant que femme dans cette idée qu'il faut toujours faire plaisir aux hommes, etc.,
se soumettre à leur volonté et tout, c'est très très compliqué, très compliqué pour toutes les femmes et notamment pour les femmes autistes.
Donc j'ai pas de conseils vraiment à donner spécifiquement aux femmes autistes. Je pense qu'il faudrait mettre en place des éducations, des interventions éducatives et, bien sûr, surtout surtout
éduquer les hommes à ne pas violer, à ne pas être des agresseurs.
D'accord. Donc ouais, je posais la question parce que je sais qu'il y a parmi nos auditrices des femmes qui sont aspies.
Et donc voilà, moi, je suis presque gêné d'avoir à leur répondre aujourd'hui, mais vous êtes impuissante quoi.
Ouais, c'est compliqué hein.
Oui.
C'est compliqué. Moi en fait, je sais que— alors je peux peut-être parler de moi du coup. Ce que je fais maintenant, c'est que je fais très très attention à partir du moment où la personne que j'ai en face de moi est un homme,
je suis sur la défensive.
Oh, c'est triste ça.
Ah oui, mais on est bien obligé. Et je fais très attention. Et si je sens que peut-être, 'fin voilà, parce qu'il y a beaucoup de sourires, parce que la personne me contacte et me recontacte, etc.
Donc je sens qu'il pourrait y avoir une ambiguïté, très vite, je vais le désamorcer en l'explicitant. C'est-à-dire en disant : « Voilà, j'ai l'impression que peut-être y a une ambiguïté entre nous.
Est-ce que je me trompe ou pas ? » En prenant les devants, expliciter, voir ce que la personne en face me dit, en fait.
J'aime bien.
Et ça, ça permet voilà de repasser par quelque chose de plus clair. Et donc à ce moment-là, ça permet de dire : « Eh ben oui, moi aussi, je suis intéressée » ou « Eh ben désolée, mais je suis pas du tout dans cet état d'esprit-là.
Donc voilà, on va arrêter là la relation quoi. »
On revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur la stratégie de coping de rationalisation, intellectualisation.
Oui, c'est ça, c'est un peu ça.
Voilà. Et du coup, y a une autre nature de personnes qui sont des prédateurs, ce sont ce qu'on appelle les pervers narcissiques.
Mmh.
Est-ce que— bon déjà, est-ce que tu peux nous rappeler ce que c'est les pervers narcissiques ?
Oh. Alors moi, je connais très très mal. Je pense que je suis pas la mieux placée pour répondre à—
D'accord, OK
...à cette question.
Je peux peut-être répondre à ma propre question alors.
Donc les pervers narcissiques, en fait, c'est,
c'est... Alors, pour employer une formule un petit peu imagée, on imagine que tu rencontres une personne que tu trouves absolument très impressionnante et très, qui, que tu— oui, qui t'impressionne à,
à de nombreux niveaux et qui te promet un grand gâteau.
Elle va t'offrir quelque chose dont tu as fort besoin et toi, tu en rêves de ce grand gâteau.
Et dans le cadre de votre relation, elle va— cette personne, ce pervers narcissique va t'offrir des petites miettes pour te dire : « Ben oui, le gâteau, il existe vraiment hein.
Je sais faire tout ça. » Et toi, tu vas goûter aux petites miettes et tu vas te dire : « Ah, mais c'est— ah, c'est tout ce dont je rêvais.
Cette personne va m'offrir ce grand gâteau. J'en ai absolument besoin. » Sauf qu'en fait, la relation qui va continuer après ça, la personne ne te donnera jamais le grand gâteau.
Mais elle— voilà, y aura une relation type dominant-dominé quoi, où tu seras manipulé pour être en permanence en adoration face à ce pervers narcissique.
Et ça, c'est, voilà, c'est typiquement une— on est en plein dans l'implicite, dans quelque chose qui n'est pas explicité.
Et là, oui, effectivement, moi, je peux dire que j'ai à deux reprises dans les dernières années, avant que je commence à m'intéresser vraiment à,
à l'autisme à un niveau psychologie sociale, je suis tombé dans le panneau au niveau, dans deux relations pendant très longtemps
qui étaient de ce type-là.
Et donc si y a des autistes qui nous écoutent, méfiez-vous. Alors, je reviens un petit peu sur ton bouquin.
Tu— dans— y a un extrait que je voulais citer. Tu dis : « Les femmes autistes ont du mal à s'imposer. Elles évitent le conflit et recherchent l'acceptation des autres.
Pour toutes ces raisons, oser un refus à une demande, quelle qu'elle soit, peut être particulièrement ardu pour elles.
» Est-ce que tu te reconnais avant et après ton diagnostic ? Est-ce qu'il y a une différence à ce niveau-là ou pas du tout ?
Alors déjà, je précise que ça, effectivement, c'est tiré d'une recherche, ces propos hein, que j'ai eus dans le livre.
Moi, est-ce que je me reconnais là-dedans ? Je me reconnais complètement là-dedans. Ce qui m'a énormément aidée sur la question de l'affirmation de soi, c'est l'hypnose.
D'accord, OK. C'est intéressant ça.
Ouais. Et j'en parle parce que je me dis si ça peut aider d'autres personnes, ça serait chouette. J'avais— ça, c'était une de mes grandes demandes.
Moi, j'ai— c'est pas compliqué. J'avais deux demandes principales, c'était me débarrasser de mon anxiété, et ça, c'est toujours pas résolu, malheureusement,
et réussir à m'affirmer, à ne pas perdre mes moyens quand on me hurle dessus ou quand on vient me chercher, etc.
Réussir à m'imposer plutôt que de m'effondrer complètement ou d'être tétanisée et de passer trois jours à ressasser le problème.
'Fin bref. Et en fait, l'hypnose m'a vraiment aidée sur la question de l'affirmation de soi. En deux séances, ça a été complètement réglé.
OK.
Incroyable, mais voilà. Ouais, ouais, incroyable.
Moi, dans mon— ouais, de là où je suis, l'hypnose, ça m'a toujours paru comme étant, tu sais, hocus pocus, tour de magie, Patrick Sébastien, tout ça.
Oui, et pourtant, tu vois. Alors, je ne sais pas comment ça marche. Est-ce que— je ne sais pas. Je suis pas capable de dire comment ni pourquoi ça a marché.
OK.
Mais ça a marché, mais vraiment de façon extrêmement flagrante.
Est-ce que c'est reconnu au niveau de la médecine, de— un psychiatre qui peut conseiller, voilà : « Tiens, l'hypnose, pour vous, ça peut être une solution. »
Alors oui, j'en ai connu, moi, des psychiatres qui l'ont fait, mais par contre, les psychiatres qui l'ont fait sur moi, ça n'avait jamais marché.
Là, c'était une thérapeute qui n'était pas psychiatre, qui faisait que de l'hypnose. C'est quand même de plus en plus reconnu, malgré les réticences qu'on peut avoir à l'égard de l'hypnose.
Mais après, ça dépend des praticiens, praticiennes, ça dépend aussi de la personne, de son ouverture. Voilà.
Moi, je sais qu'avec cette praticienne-là, alors que ça n'avait jamais marché auparavant, mais avec cette praticienne-là, en deux séances, cette question-là a été complètement réglée.
Et ben, et donc je remarque dans ton extrait que tu dis : « Les femmes autistes ». Du coup, quoi, ça, ce problème-là ne concerne pas les garçons ?
Mmh. Et bien en fait, c'est pareil, c'est tiré d'un article qui parlait des femmes et des spécificités des femmes et des raisons pour lesquelles elles peuvent se retrouver dans des situations où elles sont agressées, vulnérables, etc.
Je dis pas que ça ne concerne pas les garçons. Parce qu'effectivement, comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure, les garçons aussi, les garçons autistes aussi sont sujets, voilà, sont les proies des agressions sexuelles et autres.
Mais après, je ne sais pas dans quelles proportions. Voilà. Et comme de toute façon, on sait que les femmes sont éduquées, c'est toujours la même question hein, sont éduquées à être soumises, etc.
Bon, c'est sans doute d'autant plus vrai chez les femmes, en fait.
Yes. Mais justement, puisqu'on parle des femmes autistes, moi, j'avais envie de partager une petite histoire. Y a quelques années, je connaissais une fille qui était autiste.
'Fin en fait, non, elle ne se savait pas autiste Asperger. Et c'est une fille qui, voilà, qui partageait avec moi qu'elle avait une anorexie sévère.
Elle ne mangeait pas ou très très peu. On a mangé ensemble un jour, elle mangeait une tranche de pain et un peu de soupe.
C'est tout pour la journée. Et donc ça allait assez loin puisque ça arrivait au stade où elle était tellement, tellement mince, tellement maigre que elle ne voulait plus en fait.
Mh.
Il y avait de la part des médecins déjà une complète absence de la question de l'autisme, et carrément voilà une grosse culpabilisation de : « Mais c'est de ta faute, pourquoi tu ne manges pas ? » et cetera.
Voilà et 'fin, à l'époque, je ne comprenais pas trop et j'étais là : « Bon, je sais pas trop quoi te dire, il faudrait manger quand même.
» Et le— j'ai compris en fait des années plus tard plein d'éléments comme le fait par exemple qu'elle avait un intérêt spécifique pour les avions.
Un jour, on traversait la rue ensemble et elle a fixé l'avion comme si c'était le plus beau truc du monde qu'elle ait vu.
Alors que des avions, elle en avait vu certainement des milliers de fois avant. C'est— elle suivait les trajets des avions dans le ciel pendant toute la journée, et cetera.
Enfin, c'était un intérêt spécifique quoi. Et donc j'ai compris des années plus tard en fait que cette fille était très clairement comme moi autiste Asperger.
Et d'ailleurs, c'était marrant, on s'ignorait tous les deux autistes, mais on savait qu'on était pareil quand même.
Donc ça, c'était assez chouette. Mais du coup, j'avais envie de te poser la question. Question qui n'est pas simple évidemment, mais quand une personne s'ignore autiste, que nous, on sait qu'elle est autiste,
et qu'elle est— qu'on observe qu'elle est en intense détresse, hein, l'anorexie
a un niveau assez grave qui est donc une conséquence typique de l'autisme chez les filles.
Est-ce que c'est à nous de se permettre de lui dire : « Tiens, je pense que tu es sur le spectre autistique. » Est-ce que c'est à nous de le faire ?
C'est une question qu'on me pose très souvent et c'est vraiment délicat. Moi, ce que je dis, c'est que c'est très compliqué de le dire frontalement parce qu'on sait pas comment la personne peut réagir.
Je vois.
Mais par contre, on peut planter une petite graine et dire : « Ah bah tiens, l'autre jour, j'ai vu telle vidéo, ça m'a fait penser à toi, ça peut peut-être t'intéresser.
Je vais t'envoyer le lien. » Ou : « Tiens, j'ai lu ce bouquin, je vais te le passer. »
T'offres le bouquin de Julie Dachez un peu par hasard.
Voilà, c'est ça. Mais voilà, c'est ça. Juste hop, on donne l'information. « Oh, ça, j'ai pensé que ça t'intéresserait nanana.
» Et après, en fait—
D'accord ouais
...la personne s'en empare ou pas. Mais on peut pas faire beaucoup plus que ça. Et je pense que c'est très très délicat de le dire.
En plus, on peut se tromper aussi, hein, même si en général entre nous, on se reconnaît surtout une fois qu'on a, voilà, qu'on a compris qui on était et tout ça.
Après, c'est facile de repérer les autistes autour de soi, mais c'est quand même très délicat de dire frontalement : « Bah voilà, je pense que tu es concerné nanana. »
Donc là, tu viens de ruiner mon plan puisque j'allais envoyer ce podcast à plein d'amis en douce sans leur dire pourquoi.
Désolée.
Voilà. Et ben du coup, est-ce que— ça pose la question de cette espèce de détresse qu'on ne sait pas attribuer, sur laquelle on ne s'est pas posé un mot, le mot autisme.
Est-ce que la situation inverse est possible ? Est-ce qu'on peut être un autiste qui s'ignore, mais pas du tout être en détresse ?
Ou bien est-ce que la détresse est inévitable quand on est autiste ?
En fait, la détresse est inévitable, mais pas parce que la détresse, elle est intrinsèque à l'autisme.
C'est ça, oui. Encore une fois, c'est sociétal, c'est politique, c'est—
Exactement. Et ça, c'est intéressant parce que, alors j'ai plus les chiffres exacts en tête, mais il y a une recherche qui en parle précisément et qui parle notamment de la question du suicide en fait.
Et je crois, alors de mémoire, ça doit être 70 % des personnes dites Asperger qui ont déjà tenté de se suicider ou envisagé de se suicider.
Et pourquoi ? Eh bien, la première raison qui vient à ça, ce sont les situations de discrimination répétées qu'elles ont subies dans leur vie et qui les ont poussées au suicide en fait.
Donc je crois que c'est très compliqué d'être autiste, qu'on sache qu'on est autiste ou pas, et de ne pas être en souffrance parce qu'en fait nos comportements sont atypiques, nos comportements violent les normes sociales en vigueur,
nos comportements sont mal interprétés.
Et donc forcément, on va sans cesse être dans des situations où on va être harcelé, stigmatisé, discriminé. Donc évidemment qu'après, il y a de la souffrance.
Mh. Mh. Et donc cette souffrance, cette anxiété, tu évoquais tout à l'heure que l'hypnose, ça t'a aidée avec ça.
Ça m'a aidée sur la question de l'affirmation de soi, ouais. L'anxiété, j'ai pas encore trouvé de solution. Donc je suis preneuse.
D'accord, OK. Mais donc j'allais te demander, est-ce que tu as d'autres solutions que l'hypnose pour, voilà, ces personnes qui sont—
Moi, je sais que ce qui m'a aidée au quotidien, au niveau de la gestion de mes émotions, c'est d'avoir une hygiène de vie extrêmement stricte.
Bah là, malheureusement, je me suis blessée il y a deux semaines, donc je peux plus le faire, mais là, j'en étais arrivée à un stade où je faisais du sport tous les jours, une heure de sport intensif tous les jours.
Je mange de façon très équilibrée, je mange pas de sucre, je mange pas de gluten parce que bon, j'ai testé et j'ai vu qu'effectivement, ça m'aidait aussi.
Je mange pas de produits d'origine animale, mais là, c'est plus par conviction.
Mh.
Et ça, ça m'aide d'avoir une alimentation très très équilibrée, un rythme de vie, voilà, où je me couche tous les soirs vers 22 h, 22 h 30, pas plus.
J'essaie de dormir le plus possible, je fais du sport. Ça, ça m'aide. Ça m'aide à mieux gérer mes émotions. Mais bon, là, j'ai pu me le permettre ces derniers temps parce que j'étais au chômage.
Mais en travaillant à temps plein, c'est compliqué aussi de pouvoir se faire à manger, de pouvoir faire du sport. Donc, bon.
Mh. Mh. Ouais, je suis très jaloux puisque moi, mon hygiène de vie est absolument chaotique. Donc, il faudrait que je m'occupe de ça.
Dans ton livre, tu évoques aussi ce qu'on appelle le processus d'individuation.
Ah oui.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est et en quoi ça concerne les personnes autistes ?
Oui. Alors en fait, le processus d'individuation, ça, c'est un concept que l'on doit à Jung. Il explique, Jung, qu'il y a, voilà, d'une part chez nous, ce qu'il appelle la persona.
Et la persona, c'est ce personnage social qu'on construit, hein, depuis tout jeune, du fait de contraintes extérieures.
C'est ce rôle social que l'on va jouer. Et ça, je dis on, mais c'est on au sens large, hein, autistes et non autistes, que l'on va jouer à la face du monde.
On sait bien que voilà, on joue un petit peu un rôle quand on est au travail ou parfois quand on est avec ses amis, etc.
Donc ça, c'est la persona, c'est le personnage social. Et on a aussi l'ombre. L'ombre, c'est quoi ? Ce sont toutes les parties de nous
que l'on a reléguées au second plan parce qu'on ne les juge pas désirables ou parce qu'on n'a pas pu les exprimer en fonction du contexte dans lequel on est, etc.
Et arrivé à un certain moment dans la vie de la personne, souvent aux alentours de la quarantaine, la persona, donc le personnage social, va se fragmenter, et l'ombre va pouvoir enfin revenir à la surface et s'exprimer.
Et donc là, on en arrive au stade où, bah petit à petit, on va se reconnecter à soi-même, à son moi profond. C'est un petit peu cette citation de Pindare : « Deviens ce que tu es ».
C'est un peu ça l'idée. Et chez les personnes autistes, ça a du sens parce qu'en fait j'ai remarqué, lorsque j'ai fait des entretiens avec des personnes autistes,
que le diagnostic d'autisme, quand il est posé à l'âge adulte, il agit vraiment comme une sorte de détonateur du processus d'individuation.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a joué un rôle de façon tellement poussée pendant tellement longtemps. On a fait semblant d'être quelqu'un que l'on n'est pas.
On s'est normalisé, entre guillemets,
tellement, on a été tellement loin qu'à un moment donné, quand le diagnostic tombe, on se dit : « OK, bah là, je vais arrêter de faire ça,
ça ne fonctionne pas et je vais être qui je suis et je vais enfin être moi-même et je vais enfin m'exprimer et me respecter.
» Et donc ça, c'est assez flagrant et ça arrive aussi chez les personnes qui, par exemple, ont des maladies très très graves.
Pareil, ça les fait remettre tellement de choses en question, qu'ils et elles vont s'engager dans un processus d'individuation en conséquence.
Et donc ce que j'aime beaucoup, c'est que c'est très imagé, hein, le côté, le masque se brise et le—
Oui
...l'ombre se libère. C'est presque un film de Miyazaki. Quand on parle de cette libération, moi, j'ai envie de tisser un lien avec la question de l'émancipation.
Est-ce que, de nouveau, hein, je reviens avec ça, mais est-ce que ce moment où on se libère de ce masque, est-ce que c'est pas aussi le moment où on est plus en capacité de se libérer de, ouais, des autres conventions ?
Oui, c'est tout à fait possible parce qu'en fait, c'est de toute façon une remise en question qui est globale. Donc oui, je pense que ça peut aller ensemble, effectivement, oui.
D'accord, OK.
Et donc tu défends vraiment cette idée que les personnes autistes ont la chance de pouvoir sauter le pas plus rapidement
que les neurotypiques qui vont avoir ce processus d'individuation plutôt vers 40 ans
et d'envoyer un peu valser les conventions en même temps.
Oui, alors attention quand même, hein, parce que disons que moi, j'essaye, hein, souvent de voir le verre à moitié plein.
Mais ça se fait dans la souffrance, hein.
Oui oui, c'est sûr, oui.
Ça se fait quand même dans la souffrance, hein, on est bien placé pour le savoir. Mais au moins, on peut se dire, on peut avoir cette satisfaction-là de se dire : « Eh bien voilà,
c'est vrai qu'on en arrive à un stade dans nos vies, on se dit : Bon, perdu pour perdu, bah, je vais être moi-même, quoi.
» Tu vois, c'est un peu ça l'idée.
La seule chose, c'est que je ne vois pas très bien à quoi ça ressemble chez les neurotypiques. C'est quoi ? On parle de la crise de la quarantaine, en fait ?
C'est ça.
OK.
C'est le processus d'individuation, c'est complètement ça.
J'ai 24 ans et j'ai interviewé il y a un mois un monsieur qui s'appelle Jérôme Colin et qui parlait de sa violente crise de la quarantaine.
La question que j'ai envie de te poser, c'est est-ce que du coup, moi, autiste Asperger, qui ai fait mon— bon, enfin, je pense avoir fait mon process d'individuation,
est-ce que du coup, je suis immunisé contre la crise de la quarantaine ?
Je sais pas. On en reparlera dans 16 ans.
Ouais.
Mais... Mais je pense qu'en tout cas, y a des chances, oui, que ça soit moins violent que chez d'autres, oui.
OK. Bah, tu me préviendras en tout cas quand il sera—
Oui, avant toi.
Oui, c'est ça. Julie, on arrive à la fin de ces septante minutes ensemble. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ces jours-ci, maintenant que tu as obtenu ton doctorat exactement ?
Est-ce que tu as un projet à teaser, quelque chose sur lequel tu travailles ?
Alors, je donne des conférences.
D'accord.
En France et ailleurs, auprès d'associations, d'entreprises, sur la question de l'autisme
en entreprise. Donc là, je présente les points forts et avantages adaptatifs des personnes autistes et tous les aménagements à mettre en place, du recrutement jusqu'à la prise de poste.
Donc c'est vraiment une intervention qui est assez opérationnelle, pratico-pratique.
Et une autre intervention que je donne aussi, qui s'appelle Autisme : changer le regard, qui, là, vise à prendre un petit peu de hauteur par rapport à la définition clinique de l'autisme et
justement faire un détour par la question de la subjectivité au sein de la psychiatrie, etc., etc.
Donc plus théorique. Donc je, voilà, je donne des conférences comme ça un petit peu partout. Et puis bah j'espère pouvoir reprendre bientôt la recherche, l'enseignement.
Donc, on va voir.
OK. Donc c'est ton activité un petit peu intermédiaire entre le moment où la recherche se relance, tu donnes des conférences ?
Exactement.
Et ça se passe bien, les conférences ?
Oh bah très bien. Oui, oui, j'ai de super bons retours. Et ce qui est génial, c'est que les gens qui m'ont fait travailler me resollicitent.
Donc ça, c'est bon signe quand c'est comme ça. Donc oui, je suis très contente.
Excellent. Julie, alors, on va juste plugger un petit peu ton histoire. On le disait, tu as publié un livre qui s'appelle Dans Ta Bulle : Les autistes ont la parole, écoutons-les.
C'était en 2018, il me semble, avec une préface, justement, de Joseph Schovanec qu'on évoquait plus tôt. Tu as publié aussi une bande dessinée qui est absolument magnifique, qui est dessinée par Mademoiselle Caroline, c'est ça ?
Oui, exactement.
Voilà, La Différence Invisible, qui parle donc— mais c'est ton histoire, en fait, hein, si je comprends bien, dans les grandes lignes.
Oui, c'est mon histoire dans les grandes lignes, juste avant le diagnostic et juste après. Et en fait, La Différence Invisible, depuis sa sortie, elle a été traduite en plusieurs langues et notamment en japonais.
Et alors ça, je peux vous l'annoncer, on a appris récemment avec Caro que La Différence Invisible avait reçu un prix au Japon.
Donc on est invités fin mai à passer quelques jours au Japon pour recevoir notre prix et faire des interventions là-bas.
Donc, on est complètement hystériques. On a hâte, hâte d'y aller.
Mais l'autisme au Japon, ça doit être super intéressant parce que là-bas, ils sont justement très fort enfermés dans plein de conventions, dans des règles, ce qu'on a le droit de dire, ce qu'on a le droit de faire, etc.
Bah justement, je suis très curieuse de voir là-bas comment le culturel interagit avec cette question-là.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui, parce que—
Ça va être très intéressant.
OK. Mais tu nous raconteras. Ça m'intéresserait pas mal.
C'est sûr, je te dirai.
Alors, et enfin, on peut te retrouver sur Twitter puisque tu racontes, rappelle-moi, c'est Julie Dachez, c'est ça ?
Oui, exactement, c'est ça.
julie_dachez.
C'est ça.
Et tu donnes également, si je ne me trompe pas, du coaching. Tu fais du coaching ?
Oui, je fais un petit peu de coaching auprès de personnes autistes diagnostiquées.
D'accord.
Donc sur Nantes, qui est la ville où je vis. Voilà. Et ça, c'est chouette aussi. Je suis contente de pouvoir être utile de façon concrète, en fait, auprès de mes camarades. Donc—
Yes. Et c'est une activité qui est alors remboursée par les soins de santé ?
Non, malheureusement.
Non ?
Non, non, non, parce que déjà, bon, la psychologie ne l'est pas, le coaching non plus. Donc non, malheureusement, c'est pas remboursé.
Ici, la psychologie, c'est remboursé en petit degré, pas assez.
C'est bien déjà, c'est mieux que chez nous. Ouais
...C'est genre, c'est 15 € sur 60.
Ah. Bon.
C'est toujours ça pris.
Oui, c'est toujours ça.
Excellent. Julie, c'était un immense plaisir de te recevoir. Franchement—
Merci pour l'invitation. J'espère que j'ai été claire parce que je suis super fatiguée aujourd'hui. J'espère que ça n'a pas été trop—
Ça ne s'est pas du tout entendu.
Ah.
En tout cas, une chose est claire, c'est que si un jour tu donnes une conférence à Bruxelles, tu m'appelles tout de suite.
Oui.
Je viendrai, je ramènerai la tribu autiste bruxelloise.
Avec plaisir.
Eh bien Julie, merci beaucoup pour ces 70 minutes passées ensemble. Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
C'est déjà tout pour ces 70 minutes avec Julie Dachez. Merci à toi Julie. J'ai passé un super moment.
Avec ce troisième épisode, je pense qu'on a bien couvert le sujet de l'autisme et c'est la dernière fois qu'on en parle dans ce podcast avant un bon moment.
Dans le prochain épisode, on parlera politique puisque les élections fédérales, régionales et européennes ont eu lieu en Belgique la semaine dernière.
Vu que c'est un épisode qui concerne l'actualité, il sortira exceptionnellement dans une semaine et pas deux, contrairement à ce que je disais à Julie.
Et le moins qu'on puisse dire, c'est qu'il y aura des choses à débriefer avec la grande ascension de l'extrême droite,
la possible intervention de la Russie dans nos élections et surtout la grande difficulté qu'on aura à former un gouvernement avant un bon moment.
Je serai accompagné pour cela par trois politiciens et politiciennes, à commencer par Barbara Trachte, députée Écolo à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles,
Els Ampe, qui est députée Open VLD à la Région bruxelloise, ainsi que le socialiste Rachid Madrane, qui est ministre bruxellois pour l'Aide à la jeunesse.
Enfin, et surtout, on débriefera tout ça avec l'excellent Frédéric Chardon, journaliste politique pour La Libre Belgique.
À très bientôt. Salut !